hi how you guys doing
mary kate and ashley olsen honor their
full house co-star bob saget following
his sudden death at 65.
on sunday the entrepreneurs and former
child stars released a statement to e.t
paying tribute to their tv dad following
the news that he was found unresponsive
in a hotel room in orlando florida and
pronounced dead at the scene
bob was the most loving compassionate
and generous man we are deeply saddened
that he is no longer with us but know
that he will continue to be by our side
to guide us as gracefully as he always
has the 35 year old twins went on adding
that they are thinking of the comedian's
three daughters aubrey lara and jennifer
and his wife kelly and are sending their
condolences
the stand-up comedian shot to fame in
1987 as danny tanner on full house and
built a legacy as one of tv's greatest
dads
it's a father uh two guys that are and
all trying to raise these kids and the
youngest one is of course the most
difficult trying to change diapers and
things wow it's nice to see that my dad
talked the other morning had this much
impact on you
my dad talks never have this much impact
on me
it's more fun than i've ever had in my
whole life
of course saggett had so much fun he
later returned to his iconic role for
netflix's revival series fuller house
extra strong febreze three-ply paper
towel you're cleaning at housekeeper
level
it's
meaningful because i was 30 years old
when i started this show which means
danny tanner was 21 when he had dj and
on sunday some of saggett's other cast
members spoke out too like good friend
john stamos who tweeted quote i am
broken i am gutted i am in complete and
utter shock i will never ever have
another friend like him i love you so
much bobby kenny's camera like she's my
tv daughter candace cameron beret
tweeted that she had no words before
adding that saggitt was one of the best
human beings she's ever known it really
is family it's been over 30 years that
we've known each other there's just so
much love and that's why it makes it so
hard because with big love you feel big
loss
and on monday she shared these onset
snaps writing quote i love you so much i
don't want to say goodbye 35 years
wasn't long enough he's one of the most
sensitive people i know the heart is the
most genuine heart i've known in my life
the thing that touches me the most
they're friends of mine
they are
really friends of mine it's a gift
dave coulier who played uncle joey on
the hit 90s sitcom shared a pic with his
former co-star writing quote i'll never
let go brother love you while andrea
barber who played dj's best friend kimmy
shared a series of pics alongside a
lengthy message which read in part quote
bob ended every text every interaction
with love you didn't matter how long or
short we'd been apart he loved so deeply
and so fiercely i mean it's a love thing
that's kind of what it is and all that
echoes what the actor told et on the
final day of filming fuller house in
2019. candace
and jody and andrea
you know we love each other and we've
been friends all these years
and we've been there for each other and
people have heard all this ad nauseam
but it's
it's honestly true i mean it's a it's an
extended family the truth is we've
always loved each other and that's what
i think made the show a success it was
in between the lines that stuff that
happens when it's real between people
and to see them
to become such
beautiful
women it's just wonderful to watch it's
just it makes me so happy
you